[Applaudissements]
cinq ans et à ne pas manquer sur canal+
pour tous les abonnés qui nous regardent
vraiment c'est le show de thomas on y
croit tous coutelas est vraiment tout le
monde y croit beaucoup chez vous à tous
ses fans de touba c'est rémi garde est
fan de toujours trouvé que l'écriture
était ultra modernes ces dynamiques ses
rythmes et franchement au passé un super
moment c'est original
c'est comme un ovni j'ai adoré du début
à la fin
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme tati s'il aimait pas ta
gueule j'ai beaucoup aimé comme gilles
parce qu'il ya du rythme effectivement
ces divers mais c'est aussi la diversité
pour une fille des antilles est qu une
fille qui était au csa mais je trouve
que canal+ fait fort en osant donner aux
téléspectateurs de l'humour camerounais
de l'humour la petite touche n'a pas
attendu mais c'est du bon français
non je suis désolé je suis désolé les
autres chaînes n'ose pas mettre des
personnes avec un humour avec leur
touche personnelle à l'antenne je dirais
voilà comment je vois pas qui ne veulent
absolument pas choqué par ce que vous
dites au contraire de jeu moi j'ai dit
rien de positif mais après fait c'est
juste que je suis d'origine camerounaise
mais c'est pas j'en fais pas une
obsession et dans celles où l'on met
jamais en fin de journée si je puis me
permettre
je sais simplement que voilà c'est pas
mal je ne lève pas le matin en disant
vive le cameroun
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vive le cameroun alors la différence
c'est qu'eux voulaient pas le matin en
vous disant vive le cameroun mais les
patrons de chaînes se disent tous ça
donc la balle et moi j'étais au csa et
je vais vous dire que les chaînes qui
osent m et comme dans votre émission il
ya des digues des personnalités diverses
de diverses le choc je dis chapeau parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça ne se fait pas à la
télé aux gens leur chance voilà et moi
non plus je me lève pas le matin tous
les matins en me disant que la
guadeloupe
non non non mais je mets juste public et
c'est quoi l'idée moi ce que j'ai aimé
et je trouve que c'est une émission 3000
va être le style sort bien ah bah je
m'en sors
après c'est comme on dit tu fais et puis
c'est les gens moi je n'ai pas
influencer j'ai donc les gens qui se
sait que si elle aime tant mieux
sincèrement je me suis amusé j'ai fait
craindre à combien là il y en a jusqu'à
mi juin donc il ya sebdo madère yacine
numéro 6 numéros et après on verra à la
rentrée on est des artisans d'art venus
même pas à la rentrée j'ai des choses à
faire
elle m'a pas quoi faire des projets jean
vendre à la proroger de quoi le cinéma
de retour sur scène